been genka it takes a while to get a
firearm and death stranding when do you
get them so you don't get them until
after you finished chapter 3 which could
be many many hours after you start the
game but before then you will get other
weapons such as the bola gun non-lethal
alternatives the sticky gun which I
guess isn't really a gun but you can
it's really cool though yeah you can
have fun with it but I think a lot of
people are probably gonna be wondering
where you get firearms or you get lethal
weapons yeah once you finish chapter 3
start chapter 4 you'll get introduced to
I think what shotguns pistols and
assault rifles and you'll go through a
section which we won't spoil where
you'll be able to familiarize yourself
with these weapons but right when you
get out of there you probably won't want
to use weapons why is that yes so you
are basically told that you should never
actually kill anyone in this game
because what happens is that the dead
people will turn into V T's themselves
and there's a chance you could actually
cause a void out like you see in the
beginning of the game that is basically
the equivalent of a nuclear explosion
and it takes out an entire part of the
map so killing things not not really
something you should be doing you've
gotta dispose of it before that happens
everyone who's played in the office so
far may at that point they usually stow
their guns they only save them for
specific times however you can unlock
blood ammo you do get a little bit of a
preview of it in chapter 3 to give you a
specific gun that is meant for just
shooting beauties that use mud bullets
but later on you can actually use the
actual weapons you get that have live
ammunition to shoot blood bullets which
are specifically meant for BTS and
there's no consequence for killing those
in fact you want to kill them because
you're gonna get lots of resources from
that you get lots of kairel right yeah
you get the the chiral energy you also
depending on how you take them out you
can actually get likes from them too
because you're helping them to move on
which is kind of interesting but from
that you can use those blood bullets to
more directly attack them outside of
using the home attic
ADEs that you've been using for many
hours before that just like other blood
amma that you find it will it will take
some of your blood we didn't use this
you have to kind of be careful and then
eventually to you will also get
non-lethal rounds right yes which you
can equip with the soul rifles shotguns
and then that's kind of your I don't
know I guess get-out-of-jail-free card
because it does the same things as guns
except it doesn't actually kill people
yeah I almost always had a like a
non-lethal rifle on me at all times
you're like loaded in my truck with me
in case I belong to a mule camp and I
needed some way to get out absolutely if
you don't wanna punch anything it's
definitely the way to go I guess yeah
yeah once you unlock those which what
chapter five ish maybe later yeah five
or six thing you'll unlock those you'll
unlock non-lethal rounds and that makes
life a bit easier but those are weapons
in death stranding for the most part you
don't want to use them that much but you
will get to the point where you can use
of non-lethal weapons yeah you look
forward to that for more deaths training
stuff stay tuned game spot